I've been talking to you for a while now
and I even did a couple of interviews
about the sort of signalling that Donald
Trump has done to white nationalists and
white supremacists with the things that
he says and the policies that he
proposes and I've made the point before
and even white nationalists have made
the point before on this program that
when Trump likes top sort of short of
what would be a much more obvious
identification with white nationalism or
white supremacy or sort of established
xenophobia
if Donald Trump's statements have the
effect of coalescing those groups
if those extremists see Trump as the
best path the most likely path to
getting the world that they want it kind
of doesn't matter whether Trump is
personally a white supremacist or a
white nationalist or anti-semitic or
racist or xenophobic or whatever because
the impact on those groups and on policy
still remains if that's how he's
perceived by those individuals and
Richard Spencer one of the most well
known white nationalists I think at this
point I would say in the world was on
the program and he said we get Trump
can't say all of the things we are
choosing to ignore that Trump's daughter
converted to Judaism and Trump's
son-in-law is Jewish we understand the
signals he sends and we see him as our
best path forward and along those lines
there's a really interesting report in
the New York Daily News who spoke to a
former white nationalist named Eric
black who's actually the son of I think
it's Don black I forget the name of
another very well-known white
nationalist and Derek black explained
it's not just Trump's rhetoric that
signals white nationalists and his
language but his policies also signal
white nationalists and first thing I'm
gonna play a little clip for you here
Derek black was asked about Trump not
condemning neo-nazis at the
charlottesville March and he explained
how a white nationalist would read
Trump's statements take a look did you
say also kind of is
to condemn like like the attacks in
charlottesville and he said you know
there was bad people on both sides and
even recently he referred to himself as
a nationalist do you think it's like
there been any one event that really
kind of means you go would the fact that
he wasn't willing to condemn
Charlottesville which absolutely shocked
me because up till that point I had
thought there's a lot of overlap and the
things that he believes and the things
that white nationalists believe and that
was shocking but it could at least feel
like if he had the opportunity to mend
my Nationals that he always would and he
didn't do that and that was very
alarming the fact that he could look at
and outright white nationalist he meant
with Nazi flags and then say that there
are some of those people are really good
if what they're marching for is itself
good that was just absolutely
mind-boggling and then you get into the
material where Derek black goes on to
say during the interview that when you
look at the package of policies that
this administration has supported or
proposed or sort of shown an interest in
it's a very clear signal to white
nationalists limiting immigration from
we can say it now
[ __ ] countries and increasing
immigration from Norway or moving
immigration from those countries to
Norway that's a very clear policy signal
shutting down all Muslim immigration
earlier this week talking about
birthright citizenship at a time when
you've got a lot of the media attention
on immigrants coming from Latin American
countries where people are
disproportionately brown militarizing
the border to stop those asylum seekers
saying as the interviewer mentioned in
that clip I am a nationalist last week
or the week before when you step back
for a second and realize that Trump's
Jewish son-in-law isn't really the
important thing here you see the big
picture and this is an ex KKK guy son of
one of the most prominent white
nationalists in the country in the world
explaining how the white nationalists
see Trump and then when you see
something like this next clip you are
immediately if you're a white
nationalist going to say that is my guy
remember when Trump did this I want to
ask you about
the anti-defamation league which this
week called on you to publicly condemn
unequivocally the racism of former KKK
Grand Wizard David Duke who recently
said that voting against you at this
point would be treason to your heritage
will you unequivocally condemn David
Duke and say that you don't want his
vote or that of other white supremacists
in this election well just so you
understand I don't know anything about
David Duke okay I don't know anything
about what you're even talking about
with white supremacy or white
supremacists so I don't know I mean I
don't know did he endorse me or what's
going on because you know I know nothing
about David Duke I know nothing about
white supremacists and so you're asking
me a question that I'm supposed to be
talking about people that I know nothing
about the idea that Trump knew nothing
about it is ridiculous we later found
out that he did but does the question do
you condemn David Duke really need a
clarification 24 hours later relevant
quote Andrew Gilliam Gilliam recently
said about his opponent Ron de santis in
Florida now I'm not calling de santis a
racist I'm simply saying the racists
believe he's a racist and that is what
applies here to Donald Trump and to this
issue Richard Spencer has said it former
KKK people are saying it it's the
reality folks if he is perceived as
white nationalist or xenophobic or
whatever else by those individuals
that's what matters and he's coalescing
and activating them am I wrong
well let me know I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show I am thrilled to tell
you that one of today's sponsors is
simple habit calm slash Pakman where you
can go and get a seven day totally free
trial of an app that I use personally
and love I've talked to you before about
the benefits of meditation just simply
sitting there observing what it is that
your mind wants to do has been a great
thing for me we have so much evidence
growing all the time that this is just a
good
for people to do and one of the best
tools you'll be able to find anywhere
online for guiding you through
meditation is simple habit it just won
the 2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app a very well deserved
award they have guided meditations by
some of the most respected mindfulness
experts from the east and west you can
choose from a huge selection of
five-minute meditations each designed
specifically for where you are or what
you're doing or the mood that you're in
they have meditations for falling asleep
for when you're waking up for your daily
commute when you've just gotten home
from work there are meditations
specially crafted to help people deal
with anxiety or to get focused before
doing something difficult and simple
habit lets you keep track of your
progress by giving you feedback about
how much you're meditating how many days
in a row you've been meditating it's a
really comprehensive and well put
together app go check it out you can try
it free for seven days at simple habit
calm slash Pakman I've put a link
underneath this video